[Music]
we're very lucky to live in a bucolic
green part of the country bucolic are
you laughing about that
and um
recently i was doing some weeding i
guess i riled up a hornet i was
listening to music so i didn't hear it
and uh but i just felt this like really
sharp pain in my face
i took my headphones off and out and
then i heard that like and it occurred
to me i was being attacked by uh at
least one
act you can't be attacked by one hornet
we had a very different experience
that day i was inside and all i heard
was
and it's just the sound this like
operatic sound just kept getting closer
and closer until it's inside the house
you're like
i'm sorry you went through that that was
sucked i ran faster than but thank you
for i also did you see me flying to the
house because that would be funny oh
that must have been funny how many steps
would you say lead up that's 10 i think
i did them all in one two bounds
adrenaline adrenaline hey country living
it comes with the territory life could
be a dream
life could
you're listening to life is short i'm
your country living host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is my equally afraid
of bees if not more so so uh being
judgmental but also um afraid yourself
i've seen you in fact i've heard you
operatically scared that's a funny way
to be scared remember that time i mean i
think we've talked about this on the
show when keir jumped out from behind
there we have a yes yeah we have talked
about this but the way you express uh
fear is um operaticus was you were like
it was like from looney tunes when um
yeah your b reaction was remarkably like
what my b reaction would have been
in the same circumstance i i do i sing
my fear away
i don't know why it just that's i don't
know it's like
it's like your
most honest
self it's like it's just that's what
comes out yeah
that's so funny maggie is making fun of
me i think it was last summer it wasn't
this summer kind of stupid memory it was
last summer we were in a car we're about
to go into a grocery store and there was
one of those
um a bumblebee just landed on my pants
in the car like right before we left the
car and i was like
oh yeah
and i panicked and i like waved my hands
around so furiously and she
when i was gone i got it out out of the
car window i looked over at her and she
was like had completely lost
all respect for me
you've had some scares uh with wildlife
i was because i was also thinking about
how fast i ran and and like when the
stakes are that high i mean they
shouldn't be that high for a b
but um you've encountered you
encountered a bear a couple summers ago
when i was kayaking by myself in the
lake i think i've told this story but i
i saw bear just kind of swimming by me
it couldn't have been more than 25 feet
away from me and it was just like
very casual and
we saw each other at the same time right
my memory is that we saw each other at
the same time and
naturally i panicked and i
turned around in my boat as fast as i
possibly could and kayaked away as fast
i possibly could but the bear was
equally scared of me
stupidly uh it was if it had only known
oh my god it was threatened by me so he
so he started to swim away you would
have been such an easy meal but i swear
i i kayaked so fast i'll never forget
it's like super humid yeah another
superhuman i i've had a lot of uh
frights in my life when i was a kid
i was
treating an and
a car full of hoodlums
like neighborhood boys this is really
funny pulled over and
stole my candy and knocked me to the
ground oh that's not funny i thought
you're gonna tell me about something
else and i ran home as fast as i could i
was i was a little kid
and i remember going from point a to
point b and like
ordinarily would have taken like five
minutes i got there in like 10 seconds
yeah it was amazing it's amazing how
fast you can go and you're scared oh
like isn't it funny now to think about
those hoodlums
how they must have been how old like 14
13 14. they could drive so 16. but still
like but the hoodlums in our town were
like i know like prep like spears yeah
that's the irony kids that already had
money and like things they were just
like pricks that was shitty anyway why
are we talking about uh superhuman speed
yeah well i'll tell you our guest today
is on a show about a man who has
superhuman speed called the flash our
guest today is tom kavanagh
i'm smiling really big because i'm
thinking about how much i love tom tom
is one of those he was one of the first
people i ever worked with he remains one
of my very favorite people i know i say
that a lot on the show and i probably
get it this really applies though yeah
tom is truly the best um i wish i hadn't
been using that expression for so many
other people now because i it'd be nice
to have reserved that he was a mentor to
me when i was starting out as an actor
he
not only in terms of acting but
how to be just how to be a good person
and um
you know especially on a on a set a film
set he's one of the nicest most generous
human beings i've ever met uh and i just
i love him and this was a great
opportunity to catch up with my old uh
pal you were on a show with him called
ed oh i did i should have mentioned you
should have mentioned that
yeah and he played the role of ed yeah
it wasn't like a big brother program
uh i have a big brother who i also love
um i wonder if how many of people
listening now saw that like what
percentage i would guess maybe less than
15 less than 10 maybe
don't you think i don't know i mean it
was a pretty obscure show even for then
though there were so few shows then you
know youngsters won't know it for sure
because it's not streaming you can't
find it anywhere it's not in any stream
that you can find looking right so if
you weren't like a tv watching audience
member between the years of 2000 2003
chances are you've never even heard of
this show that's true it was about a
lawyer who moves from the big city to
his small town that he grew up in uh in
order to pursue the his dream girl from
high school that the one that got away
and um he opens up a law firm in a
bowling alley so hopefully one day it'll
be in some stream it was a great show uh
and he was great in it and it was
he and former guest julie bowen were the
two
stars of the show and justin played a
young high school
nerdy boy along with another former
guest the show jennifer goodwin that's
right so this is the third yes member of
ed and hopefully there will be a couple
more i hope so um because i just love
reminiscing about those times it may not
be the most relatable thing because like
we said many of you haven't seen it but
uh tom is just
regardless i think you'll really all be
charmed by him he is uh just
effortlessly charming and great so uh
here it is my catch up with my old
friend and mentor uh tom cavanaugh
life could be a dream
[Music]
i am so sorry i'm like i can't even
begin
to explain the technical difficulties
but it's so embarrassing because i i was
so ready to be like um on time and
because i i know when years when i was a
young buck and we worked together i i
think correct me if i'm wrong
i was often late
is that true yeah that's right i thought
i'm going to show tom how much i've
evolved and i'm going to be an adult i'm
going to be on time
i i i've been panicking the last 20
minutes you know what's so great is you
always had this thing which you clearly
still do is like you could be late you
show up and everyone's like justin's
here
it's really annoying don't get me wrong
but it's awesome that you carry that
with you it's like dude when he shows up
people aren't mad at him they're happy
to see him that's a great great thing my
first major job was with you and and
people who seemed so grateful to be
have a job like that to be on to be on
ed you were the lead of the show um
and i'm and i'm sure we've both
witnessed since then
you probably before then people who
didn't behave that way and um
do you remember
how
your first
formative experience with somebody who
behaved that way was and and that you
thought oh i wanna that's
that's how i should be
i remember a specific incident
and not to name names but um you know i
did like a decade of theater
i didn't have to go through what you
went through which is great in one way
and i think it's a challenge in other
ways in that you became
very famous very young and by the time i
you know had any kind of profile when we
were doing uh
our show together
i was less corruptable you know i i that
the gratitude that you sensed was like i
couldn't believe it i'm like i'm living
in new york
i'm working with you and josh and julie
bowen and just all the you know i'm
working with rob burnett who runs the
letterman show like i just couldn't kind
of couldn't when you like insane asylum
theater did not seem
very far off in the past and yeah well
how far off had it been tom sorry how
because give me an idea of the timeline
of that i would say
well i think ed er we first started
kicking a can of that at
98 i think that was the first yeah it's
a long long time ago but you might
recall we didn't do it right away
just like everything else you're like oh
of course this thing won't go
or you know we had to struggle to
finally
get to set and actually have a show like
most television shows never go through
that process where we shot a pilot
and then they didn't pick up the pilot
but they didn't outright cancel us and
then we waited a year and then shot a
pilot for a different network i don't
know that yeah it's very rare i think
leading up to that though how um prior
to your involvement with ed how many how
many of those pilots have you done how
many
did you have
much experience ten years before that
i'd been doing um broadway and uh i kind
of thought
walking down from my little place on
72nd walking down to
you know the virginia theater on 52nd
just like this is the greatest thing in
the history of great things you know
like to
live and act in new york it was just uh
it was incredible and then
i tried pilot season between theater
season i was in uh
los angeles i got a pilot it didn't go
and that was heartbreaking and another
pilot it didn't go and heartbreaking
it's that thing really i think people
say ah like i remember when we were
doing press for ed it was like
new guy
and you were like yeah
you know yeah right you know new guy
like 12 years in the you know what i
mean but it's just like great you can
say anything you want i'm just so happy
to be here so grateful to be here you
know and the good thing about that is
if there's been like 12 years of work
and also a lot of it is working in
canada where we tend not to like
shine spotlights
on our people who are working regularly
canada doesn't or at the time didn't
quite have the same mill turning behind
people who were acting up there like
myself and my friends and so um in new
york you feel like you're
on top of the world when you're doing
broadway but i think people across north
america
don't say hey um
ben platt is killing it
you know yeah um yeah this is not it's
not a it's a big big part of the
theater community it doesn't translate
as much as phil the way film and
television so so tom was there the
desire among those canadian actors to
to go to america and then and kind of
make it
in america as opposed to canada or or
were people for the most part happy
with that separation
i can't speak for
that community i think you'll find
variations
of all sorts you'll find people who
you know one of my best friends has been
kevin julianville is his name you can
imdb google him he's like done
everything with the biggest names for as
long as i've been doing it hollywood
isn't his thing
i think the the lure and the pull of
like hollywood is hard to resist tom
what was the lure for you i mean what
was that ambition do you think i would
say i would ask you like how do you know
you're an actor i mean i know your
family history
but
how does somebody know that it's the
same question for you like how do you
how do you go well
yeah it's a good i think i would say at
the time i identified
so
clearly with being an actor
i didn't think there could be a
separation between one's identity and
one's career and i loved acting i felt
excited and liberated and the most
heightened sense of joy when i was
acting
so i knew it was something that i loved
i think it was just in the doing it that
i knew that yeah
for me i think it felt more like being
pulled
something that you sort of avoided for a
little bit but knew you had to do
there were other forces saying okay you
got to go to new york you got to go to
hollywood like i really honestly felt
like being drawn and going and packing
the car up and just going down you know
you know julie i think had a similar
path into it and i think that the thing
that you guys have in common is that i
hope this doesn't sound insulting to
other actors i can imagine
you're both so capable of doing so many
other things you know like um you're
both very bright you were exposed to a
lot as as kids it's definitely not a
life that i'm sure your your parents
were
and i don't want to put words in their
mouth were they eager for you to pursue
that well you're touched by the greatest
fortune
professionally if you sort of know what
you are it was a lanford wilson play
called angel's fall
one of the characters
realized tennis was for him and he said
i hit that first ace and that was it
that was it i think this is me
and once you know who you are the rest
is just work that's the line
and i think that's very important to be
an actor because you have to i think
some people maybe do it and maybe even
do well at it but it might not be
exactly who they're
meant to be and that brings struggle and
difficulty with them whereas if there's
no option and it just is who you are it
makes all the rejection all the
difficult things that much easier
because like well i'm just going to
forge fourth because i'm not going to go
do the other things the answer to your
question is you know my father was uh
has always been
go with your heart
and let my mother is the eldest of
an italian
family that you know her grandfather
came over from italy and you know they
worked in a quaker oats factory
supporting all a household of a massive
household of children and she was much
more practical and she was like you know
use your degrees you know
pay off your student loan
and then be an actor you know
yeah and i had to say to her at some
point like well i think around the time
we were doing headers like mom i'm never
going to do that
also things are working out things
things are okay right now your mother
should be looking out for you and you've
been directing flash as well tom
when you were talking about wanting to
be an actor and the joy of
knowing that um the confidence in
knowing that that's what you wanted to
do it was directing something that you
would always imagine yourself doing no
oh no gosh no um
i mean i think you know the upcoming
generation is familiar with like because
of the social media and you know like
the technology that's available
it's not foreign to them to put together
a video project when i started it felt
like well you had to go to usc film
school yeah
director yeah well you know you can't
just direct and then we're doing this
movie with this guy uh who had been a
producer of robert redford's and his
name's rick stevenson by the way came on
we became friends he came on and
directed a uh an episode of ed um but
we've done this movie
and he was young and hip and you know
had the hollywood bonafides and was just
like god this guy we were a bunch of
young actors
working with him shooting in the in the
woods it was just he was just great he
rarely directed us these young actors
and at one point you know um i asked him
about it
and it was like the thing with you i
said about the third but he's like the
best thing i can do as a director is
cast well and then get out of the way
he was he was modest but the more i do
it the more i see like there's a massive
amount of truth
in that and so
because
not knowing anything about directing
there was this uh
you know uh
uh we'd written this movie and wanted
him to direct
and he was like you direct it
what are you talking about he's like i i
i don't i don't direct he's like well
you know what the camera's doing you
know what the story is he's like when
you when you wrote it did you see what
the scene looked like in your head yes
put the camera there
honestly
without him i don't know like it's
directing it brings me so much joy like
like i say sitting watching
talented people do their thing it's just
like
you kind of can't believe it you just
feel like it really is an incredible
gift and i feel like a lot of that
gift i owe to iota rick with that advice
your job is to facilitate
good actors uh being good and i my
brother and i just directed our first
thing and
watching melanie linsky and judy greer
just just go at it and and get into
these scenes it was such i'm getting
goosebumps thinking about it it was like
a it's a a thrill i'll tell you a judy
greer story there was a thing so we were
doing a thing together and we were
playing sort of uh paramours that hadn't
really gotten to that further point of
their relationship and still will they
won't they so you're stuck on third base
yeah
but i had this camera a friend of ours
had uh had a baby and uh you know it was
all about that tumult and then we
managed to catch eyes
julie bone did this too on this one
episode uh i directed where it's just
like i sort of pictured it like people
catching eyes across a room sort of
thing and with yeah i had had this slow
push of the camera
right and we're supposed to look at each
other's eyes and it's like maybe this is
us one day a child you know that kind
that sort of stuff is that the prom
episode tom oh god you're so good with
julie bone it was the prom episode yes
well i i love that episode and i i
i know exactly that moment you're
talking about i that [ __ ] is so hard to
capture
it's so hard to capture silently too
yeah and and julie is one like it's like
it's like you it's like you you tell
somebody something and then they're like
i know what you what you want and i'm
going to exceed that i'm going to make
it better
julie we got the amy manns you're an
amateur which is like a needle drop
which is incredible and julie's kind of
like you know julie sort of intakes
breath when she was you know when she
was doing these scenes where she needed
to command the thing it felt like when
julie would breathe in
she would bring the entire room in with
her
and you couldn't not watch her and judy
greer the same sort of thing i did with
the shot design was like a slow camera
push on judy and she's supposed to look
up and catch my eyes
and so the camera pushes and i'm like
maybe she didn't understand what i'm
saying because she's not looking up at
the last second she kind of just lifts
her eyelids and her eyes and it was so
much better it was just like
and i was like oh god you're good you
get goosebumps you get thrilled yeah
there's nothing like it nothing like it
and and in judy greer's case it was it
struck me and julie was similar they
could do it
right after having talked about what
they were going to make for dinner or
what you know what some date that they
went on the week before and like those
people are freaks to me judy and
julie bowen um but you mentioned judy
like a take after a push in where she
she looks up that strikes me as so
technical i i remember when i was
working with you
and we were talking about theater i had
only done theater and so i really relied
on
feeling something and instinct and i
didn't want to be aware of the camera i
i remember romanticizing stories about
you know
brando or these guys who they don't even
care about the camera where the camera's
not even there you know
and um but what i learned from you is
something that you mentioned judy did
which is
it was the first time that i i
realized how important in an awareness
of the camera
was in acting
and there was a way to do both there was
a way to incorporate an awareness of the
camera to be smart about
uh you know where you were looking about
angles and stuff and
and editing and also be deeply committed
to the scene that's something that you
were yeah able to do and brando said
this quote which i write on all my
scripts which was in theater he said you
have to show the audience what you're
thinking
on film you just have to think it but
the trick is the thing that separates i
think good acting from other acting is
they actually
thinking the thought
some people are preparing the next line
but there's a vacancy totally the wheels
are spinning and they've got something
going on and they're thinking about
something and you you're drawn in you
know and ed you were the lead of the
show um
we did it for four years do you remember
was there a point at which you
kind of knew the show was in trouble you
you knew that maybe they had run out of
ideas
did you ever feel like well it's
it's so funny right i mean in season one
around episode six rob and i were
driving back into the city at that point
nbc loved us and we had a handshake deal
that we we would do
four
or five seasons and i think very early
on we sort of found out what it was like
to not be
wanted you know and not in a bad way
they kept an hour-long show that had you
know a lot of comedy you know they took
away a half hour of comedy from their
lineup and just gave it to us so that
was a semi-generous
thing to do but there was always this
sense i think you might recall that we
were not assured of
not being canceled at any point you know
and then right i remember at the end of
every season it was like oh
i hope i come back yeah like michael
back when we got picked up for the back
nine on the first season like literally
collapsed it was like oh oh i can i can
pay my mortgage you know i can buy
that's not one of those things where
it's like we weren't
one of the lovely things about that show
was a we did have job security in like
in ways that
it's rare to have
in the sense that hey you're going to do
this for a year could end up being four
years that was one thing the other thing
about not being west wing or friends on
nbc
we were so grateful to have that job we
weren't thinking we weren't reading
press going like yeah we we are good you
know and those shows were those shows
were spectacular so they should they
should have gotten the accolades and the
money that they got i remember being so
incredibly grateful for it and i think
the idea that it could be yanked from us
at any time made you even more grateful
where people often asking you
about julie and about you guys on the
show getting together and then in life
getting together as i recall people were
always trying to set you up you were
like
you were such a sought after um like a
bachelor kind of guy yeah did that
happen a lot in the city
yeah it was funny right it was funny um
i think julie had gone through i think a
bit of a breakup and you know she got
asked out more than any human being
and yeah at one point we're so close you
know we
got along so well like she's yeah he's
just such an incredibly good human being
and so
as a a friend you know you try and be
there for a while you know this stuff
was happening and at one point i was
like you know you got to say yes to
something you know you got to get back
out there kind of idea you know and say
yes to some of these requests and he
said you don't have to marry anybody
just like go out for lunch and she's
like i tell you what tom cavanaugh i
will if you will
because up until then i've been like
i'm just doing this show this is the
greatest
you know that you know and time
consuming i mean so time consuming yeah
and i was you know as you know me i was
like built for it like 16 hour days like
i couldn't get enough i was just like it
was breathing oxygen like the fact that
rob was like
you know rob and john like this is our
guy he's like what me you know i was
just so like wanted to not let them down
and another thing that i've come to
appreciate even more is that you had
such a well of energy i had a good five
six hours in my tank but you would go
all day and you were smiling and you
were keeping people buoyant and that's
rare again gratitude to be doing the
thing that you love with the people that
you love that was an incredible
experience so on that dating thing you
would do the same thing so i would go on
these dates and there'd be disasters you
know like you know it was only when i
kind of like ah maybe that's not in the
cards you know and then i met the woman
i married were they disastrous because
people had an expect these women would
have an expectation of you and they were
like oh i'm going out with ed i'm going
out with the guy on tv i'm not trying to
deflect
at all yeah but i think your story there
is much more interesting than mine
because you know at the age you were at
and you you know you i think you went
through this thing was like ed was
it had a what i like to think of just
like the perfect size profile we weren't
inundated and people knew of it
but
you know not everybody was watching it
like religiously the way you know a west
wing sort of thing was right uh which we
said yeah yeah that's true and so people
were aware of
me and aware of you and aware of julie
but it wasn't like the profile julie had
when she went on and did modern family
and one any afternoon right it was just
like she's like a household thing and so
people were aware of you and then
you took your talents and didn't you
weren't typecast because
they weren't aware enough of us they
registered justin long's name now let me
see what he can do and then you walk in
a room and audition for whatever movie
and they're like holy crap well yeah to
this day i don't think i i've
occasionally get oh ed you're talking
but it's certainly not a little divorcee
right is that what you're after
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
you have a different experience now like
you mentioned julie on modern family
you must have that on on flat on the
flash the flash is like a map it's
certainly massive with a younger
audience um in fact i'm sure a lot of
your audience on that show
isn't even aware of ed i would say
probably the majority of them most
people aren't aware of it it's so funny
like
we're the only show
that you know got 22 million viewers on
nbc show and did quite well for
themselves won some awards and no one's
ever heard of us because of all the
shows that stream that's the only one of
the major what occasional from that era
that you can't can't access nobody's
aware of it i'm sure people ask you that
all the time why is that do you have a
good is it the music licensing is it the
for the seven people listening who want
to know
yeah
why is that um
i i honestly don't you'd have to ask
robert i don't have it's been explained
to me as
we had great music during that show and
i think partially because of the
letterman connection and now the music
rights in perpetuity um there's a
obstacle there it seems to me
as someone who's done this for a few
decades it seems to me like that
shouldn't
be well i can't do it
i know i know a stumbling block you run
into we did i just did i just did an
episode of flash and i wanted to get um
a huey lewis song back in time so
literally we were
back and forth with the music and this
kind of thing and then we got it you
know and i was like
you know and so i was kind of like and
it took
three quarters of a day you know maybe
two days to
sign off and i was kind of like you know
driving home going like wait a minute
okay that's it
look at the scenes that justin and i did
together all those years ago be up
streaming you know like sucks it sucks
because i also have great because i was
i was really into the um they would give
me outtakes they would give me dailies i
wanna see that so i gotta send you some
of these i will send you some i have the
best uh such fun stuff if you look at
what's happening in the world and
everybody's sort of looking for
feel-good content
certainly yeah that show kind of checked
that box like it's a solid family show
you know yeah there's not a lot of blood
and semen you know there's no
not a lot season four there was more
semen
um like a show that you can kind of like
it kind of should be on there but it's
not yeah i think i know the answer to
this but did you was there an adjustment
period after ed ended and then you i
know you started doing scrubs um which
is another huge show but
uh was there a period where you were
like ah [ __ ] now what am i gonna do i'm
back you know i'm back
auditioning and and trying to get out
there
i mean i i'd ask you the same question
like how are you when a project ends i
think everybody i
sort of
i'm i don't look back you know what i
mean and so yeah i i i try to just like
okay this is what we're what we're doing
now and i don't know how healthy the
psychology is behind that but i also
like i say try to proceed from gratitude
so i was like completely grateful for
everything that we've had and
you know grateful that i had had that
opportunity and that was my mindset now
let's see
you know what else there is to do you
know i i don't think it's ever easy
for a project that you love
to end right i think you know even when
you know you're doing theater and you
have a close date but you love it it's
it's hard you know but that's just part
of we knew ed would end it probably one
point sooner than later and so the one
thing i am grateful for is i've been
part of shows and i'm sure you've been
part of things where
um
you're set to do it and then you don't
get to do it
you know and and that's difficult in its
own right isn't it and the nice thing
about ours is like they basically told
us you're not coming back
and so
we knew and we could
we could say goodbye together and
there's a grace to that i think
yeah yeah did um when people uh when you
run into crew members now i'm thinking
about all these people
uh do you how often do you see uh like
josh randall or how often do you see
these people do you
uh ever see them in vancouver i don't
see anybody as much as i would like but
they're in my heart for sure and i do a
podcast can i can i plug another podcast
called mate oh yeah michael lee in black
what's it called tom tom and mikey
yes mates mike and tom eat snacks and we
did that we came out of that podcast
basically because on ed our favorite
thing was lunch and he would count down
if you remember this he would count down
two hours of lunch hour to lunch i'm not
gonna snack now because it's 45 minutes
we made a podcast called mike and tom
eat snacks for the sole purpose of
getting together you know
oh my god that's great if anyone's gonna
like this podcast you like this podcast
because basically what this podcast is
justin is
the moments between
cut and action where we're just waiting
for you to set stuff up we're having
snacks like i i urge you to start with
episode 27 lauren the dune it's not
really got it's learning doing
shortbread but michael
tells a story about how he was the main
guy
cast for um
uh swear again in uh deadwood
and
like you you were the guy like you the
the skinny little uh and he was like oh
yeah i walked in they just knew they
just knew it was me and he tells like a
40-minute tale about how he got
laryngitis and um and then you know he
had brought what's his name ian mcshane
from the old wicked to be a background
performer because he tries to help his
friends out
and i'm like um but doesn't larry just
go away that we didn't know back then we
didn't know
we thought that was
and he's so dry he's so dry that i'm
sure people listening to that are like
oh my god this is an action that's
really really good
on his twitter account he's got nine
years in the nfl two rings and he's
still
that's his like header and he's still
gonna
look at people going like i don't
remember you i don't remember
who'd you play for
that's amazing
this is my colleen black from um the
state and white hot american summer i i
always wanted to make him laugh
to get a laugh out of michael was like
oh man my day was made
so you had mentioned going to vancouver
and thinking was going to be temporary
when you realize that that show's going
to be a hit and it's going to be on for
a while what does that mean in terms of
now are you like oh [ __ ] i gotta move my
whole family up there is it a welcome
thing is it exciting as you know it's
like oh we're gonna have uh employment
you know
that we can count on that's uh that's an
impressive thing for a while uh
greg berlanti who runs the you know like
uh he's just such a prolific hollywood
producer and this is our third show
together he kept casting me in parts
that were
not like the nice guy and this part is
the flash is essentially like the
villain and what was interesting is like
after doing that for a bit like the
interest that we came in would be like
sort of like bad guys you know so like i
was really grateful i think
yeah like what the show
uh offered to be seen sort of a um in
another way in a different light because
that's not easy to shake i mean when
you're the nice guy when you're like in
that so indelible as the nice guy in
people's mind i mean that's
you need somebody like greg berlanti
with that kind of juice have you had
that do you find i mean people are
always like oh god yeah you know tom the
big thing for me that i had to get past
was um
of all things the commercial those apple
commercials and i thought it was going
to be a one-off kind of thing and i
thought they were gonna have me play the
pc because i'd only been playing kind of
nerdy
character parts up until then and he
said no no they want you to play
the quote-unquote cool guy and and that
was exciting at the time i was like oh
cool that you know everyone's all the
nerdy guys want to be the cool guy
so i i did it and then um
we did another round of them and then
another year of them and then they
became like this it became a big
kind of ubiquitous thing and um and i
started getting offers
from that to play the cool guy the
leading guy and i thought okay that's
exciting in a movie i get to play the
cool guy
and you know in retrospect i'm grateful
for all of them i think what that did
was uh
it then yeah you start playing that same
part and
you didn't want to say it on ed but i'll
say it it's it's not as fun
uh playing a cool guy playing a guy
who's
you know who's got to carry everything
and he's got to make the right choices
and it's it's so much more fun i feel
like we're two nice guys you know and as
an actor you want to play the guy that
you're not necessarily uh
you want to explore the darkness a
little bit yeah the good thing one thing
that
um the cool guy
as portrayed by you and those
commercials but in subsequent roles that
you would see is like
your guy was also like nobody was saying
but don't be funny you know what i mean
like which thank god you know what i
mean like you had the ability to bring
like not not overt comedy but like um
you know just like a subtle
you know wink or whatever the thing was
yeah yeah
yeah as opposed to
which i think is just the boring
straight guy yeah and i think that's
important because i think it's easy to
get into that other thing for the for
the cool guys like no no we're gonna
we're gonna give like the humor to the
slapstick buddy but not you yeah
because
you know cool guys aren't funny but you
managed to bridge that those two things
i think you told a story about your dad
and i'm blanking on it on michael on
rosie's podcast oh yeah
about about a piece of advice that he
gave you but i also remember you had a
fascinating upbringing you traveled a
lot and i remember ghana specifically
as you know justin my father uh recently
passed away and uh you you reflect on a
lot of things you're never really ready
to have a loved one pass on but when
they do
and you can look at their
life and say like they didn't leave
those stones unturned they did good
and they made the most of their time
that's a that's a brilliant thing you
know i uh
i'm grateful you know because i know he
he was grateful for
the experiences he had and you know his
one of his favorite sentences or phrases
is count your blessings count your
blessings and he saw that we'd be in
difficult situations in africa or
whatever and you know he'd find some
positive
you know to come out of it he moved to
africa and there was no
house where there was supposed to be a
house at this college that he was
teaching at for his family and they
didn't have a place oh my god can you
imagine like up ending bringing your
your family you know a big family with
little children yeah you know where for
you to live you can slip on these sleep
on these concrete floors which we did
oh you wanted a real house well no
there's no no there's no house but what
do you say i think you said a louse
and it dovetails into what he said at
college which is like he said you know
you don't want to worry about
the little things
because they're not worth worrying about
and the big things take care of
themselves so don't worry because you
can
you can
try not to and this is coming from a
person who was a worrier um and then
was he really yeah like he was
genetically predisposed to like have
concerns and he fought to overcome those
which i think makes it even that much
more compelling because it wasn't
naturally easy breezy like hey it's all
fine you know it's like he saw the
difficulty and he could fall down and
into the difficulty or he could try to
overcome it you know which is you know
that had a big thing about over about
influencing
the the acting in that i i think you
know this but um i think there's a
massive difference between
playing the obstacle or playing the
overcoming of the obstacle i think the
playing overcoming the obstacle is much
more interesting to do and much more
interesting to watch people want to lean
in to see that person who's not having
pity on themselves about the obstacle
and i think my father was that way the
other thing he said was
um as he dropped me off in college he
said if i want to
i could have worried about money every
day of my life
that's a tremendous thing to say to
someone who who's going to go into
profession where you can you can worry
about money
all the time right and yeah and now like
when i look at like the state of the
world and how difficult it is like real
really difficult it is for so many
people
i appreciate that i was guided by
someone smarter than me to go like
there's much bigger
problems out there than the stuff that
you're dealing with and so you need to
be aware to put your worries in the
right place i'm really grateful to him i
didn't know him but uh
he really made a an incredible person
and and i i bet he was so proud of you i
bet he was just
you're just one of the best and i i owe
you so much and i'm i'm you know so
grateful to you and so i'm grateful to
him
um so i'm
really really always will be
what what happened when you did show up
in ghana and there was nothing there for
him i mean how many kids were there do
you have recollections of that sure oh
yeah there was four there was four kids
at the time and
soon to be five
um and you were the youngest right i was
not i was the second eldest i have three
younger sisters oh he's an older brother
oh wow
but what i remember is they had such big
shift to deal with
that
we could do anything we wanted and for
the like nobody there was no
repercussions so i i just think you
remember that um the college you could
have tea
and you could put sugar in and we were
not allowed to have sugar really and i
could put as much effing sugar as i
wanted in that tea i could make like
sugar with a little bit of tea and no
one was like taking it out of my hands
they're busy trying to find housing you
know
yeah
little little sugar hills with like a
droplet of tea on top on the beach here
i can eat tea infused sugar this is
great you know was there wildlife all
around and was it really like untamed
you know we were on the coast of africa
and uh a lot of green a lot of
vegetation i remember there were
early on like
you saw a lot of snakes which you know
snakes why did it have to be snakes um
yeah but then you just kind of got used
to it it wasn't so it wasn't like
serengeti safari life it was you know
coastal it's more tropical coastal
tropical vibe you know big fishing wow a
big fishing place yeah tremendous
tremendous place and and how long were
you there tom so the family spent three
years in ghana and he went three years
in
malawi
um oh wow and my sister spent three
years or maybe more i might have this
wrong in zimbabwe we do the same with
nothing but nets and so i went back to
like hand out like it's for malaria nets
um yeah
went back to all these refugee camps in
uganda and uh so i've actually you know
for a north american spent
you know years worth of time in africa
and don't profess to know it at all it's
so strange right it's like every
every place is just so different from
every place it's just
it's uh it's just so eye-opening and
even as somebody who spent you know part
of his youth there don't really profess
to know it at all but great wow
do you so you still go back with with
nothing but gnats i haven't been back in
anywhere near as much as uh
the idea there so nothing but nazis um
the whole idea was to like counter
malaria by providing nets to families
very simple pipeline where ten dollars
bought you a net and then you could
count the net and then you can handle
net out so
i like that part of it it wasn't a
difficult
uh pipeline so we started like you know
just uh
trying to
post like basketball related events to
raise money and stuff and take take nets
over um
uh it's very you know like the the stats
about how
efficient it is to combat malaria with a
net are
stunning you know it's just that yeah
the cavity rate just plummets and um so
yeah
what's up
dotnet just
nothing nothing but nets.net oh thank
god it's dotnet and um right
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
do you use emojis when you text are you
an emoji you're terrible yeah i sure do
you don't i do you do i do well
this is not terrible i'm asking a
question about what is what your most
commonly used one is what what is your
go-to i'd like to see your whole lineup
your most recently used i'm sure there's
an eggplant in there
um
i'm
guessing there's a turd i don't think
i've ever sent a turd what's your i feel
like i do a lot of uh this one oh the
teeth kind of
you know like oh sorry
you know like the teeth together
clenched um i do
a kind of like submissive smiley one
like looking down a little bit a lot i
punctuate a lot with like okay
um
you know i'll do the cherry and the
eggplant i'm not i'm not above it yeah
yeah
i think a little sprinkle of water
that's good stuff
i think mine are like it's just boring
it's like there's like a you know a blue
heart and a
yellow heart and a a baseball a lot of
baseball this guy what
yeah yeah they're really excited that's
yeah i could see that that's you that's
tim busfield that's tim's face i like
that you have this one
that that that that's funny to me i got
it
because it's like sorry
i don't know
that's strong uh
it's useful
um if you could be a pro i i know this
one but if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play oh man
and why that's such a great question
because it'd have to be basketball right
you played in college yeah and it would
be uh i think would have to be
basketball because it was like you know
because of the college thing and all
this but i've also had this story like
this idea like when you discuss it's
like well wait a minute
basketball
it takes a toll
hockey i'm canadian
you know i i still play rob burnett and
i still play in a hockey league together
oh really yeah true story
and it's great it's good you know rob
rob doesn't do anything halfway
rob has a rink rob has jerseys rob has a
scoreboard rob has plexiglas rob has
like it's what it's incredible and it is
the highlight of the week for so many of
the people who gather you know in the
barn and like put on the skates and go
play and it's just it's incredible i
still play hockey
the thing though is like you could
you could be a baseball pitcher
throw once every five days and play till
40 you could have a punch
you could do that in like you know you
could actually have a little longevity
these people make 60 billion dollars you
know a season it's like hmm
so now you were playing basketball all
the time now that i'm remembering wasn't
there hoop right off said uh that was
one of the yeah that was one of the two
things i had in my contract that we had
to like like in terms of perks like we
we had a hoop you know we had to put a
hoop on set
and you're playing vancouver still you
got a league in vancouver it's
interesting because there's an acting
community wherever you go right and uh
yeah it was the same thing with the
basketball community like when i moved
to new york like some of the people i
came closest with were people who i
didn't even really know their last names
they were just guys that i played
basketball with
you know in the week you know like we
would just see each other and we would
play hoops and you'd hang out afterwards
and you know no one knew it you know
like there was no hierarchy we were just
ball players which i love you know and
so every town i've gone to you kind of
discover that it's a welcoming you know
it's nice to have a community that will
welcome you because of a show yeah
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would that be
you know you
you're talking to a professional so this
is uh
yeah
you got very serious yeah i did i was
like oh man come on tom just exhaled in
a very serious way i will say this like
people ask you know like because i i do
a superhero show i hear like if you
could have one superpower uh we're
getting to that i'm prone that i'm prone
to saying
the ability to eat
pizza
with no deleterious effect oh that's
good
i mean it's not it's very selfish yeah
yeah there's not much you could there's
how much you can do with that superpower
for other people
excuse me you're helping the local pizza
place that's just building
no i'm i can't give me one minute oh
right okay i left the building
can't right now the cheese is gonna
congeal you could have one snack but
what would it be you know pirate's booty
yes they make a cheddar puff yeah
do you know
jamaica
have you heard of i don't know i don't
know
i don't know what canadians are into
well canadians have things that we've
never heard of i'm sure
poutine yeah yeah poutine
but i'm sure there are candies that are
like well you know bloodblubs right
uh
it's sort of like a blablabe
pizza flavored goldfish too are hard for
me to put down see i i
often occasionally get do i have a
little weed and um i'll get snacky and
yeah there's certain foods if there's a
bag i have to play tricks with myself i
have to like wrap it up really tightly
and put it somewhere that you know oh
yeah yeah somewhere
it's difficult to get to
those are my poisons chess men
pepperage farm
yeah what's your favorite movie of all
time or or an easier question i guess
would be
what would your like quarantine comfort
movie be if you wanted a something you
you're like you're with your kids you're
like i can't wait to show this to you
probably die hard but not die hard the
first one the fourth one maybe
um
all right good answer you know what's
funny about watching that is knowing you
as i know and like i don't know bruce
lewis at all but i imagine him going
this [ __ ] guy
well well you know it's funny when i was
thinking about your patience
and thinking about other experiences
i've had with people who you know
have less patience
uh
yeah some people have less less patience
than you tom i'm bruce damn willis
stop improving yeah
you know comfort food
um
for me like there's certain movies that
anytime they come on you know i'll just
be like all right i'm sitting down and
doing this i guess you know what's
interesting enough is die hard shows all
the time that that's definitely that is
one of them you know in um
popo greenwich village
worth definitely definitely worth seeing
i wonder if there's any other stuff i
could throw out that i like like
gallipoli i don't you've seen gallipoli
there's like different oh glibly yeah
like the buddy movie genre like midnight
run oh yeah what about bob you like what
about bob yeah good genre i love that
genre gallipoli is so [ __ ] good i
haven't heard that yeah yeah years
on not unsung but things that maybe
wouldn't be in the mainstream right now
you know what i mean
yeah it's funny you mentioned brando's
like street car i'll watch like the i'll
watch his opening scene streetcar like
again and again and again just like what
is you doing i remember remember
what an effect that had on me as a young
actor watching him in that movie
um and not being being able to
articulate
what it was that
he was doing
you know but just knowing that whatever
it was he was doing was i couldn't take
my eyes off him you know like in that
how much of an effect
that had because there's a grail that
you want to go go grasp right yeah and
and then it becomes um when you realize
that that's a profession
something that you could do as an adult
then it becomes so exciting that the
idea of doing that becomes so compelling
to be able to affect
i remember seeing stan by me and
watching that scene with the river
phoenix where he's talking about the
stolen lunch money and i and those were
kids my age you know and i remember
thinking like
i was so affected by what i was seeing
them do
um and there were no effects there were
no it was just
it was just two people being present um
if you had to live somewhere else where
would it be
um i i love the fact that i get to split
the time between new york and vancouver
you know um yeah most new yorkers are
like new york where else are we going to
live you know
if it was just pure fantasy
um i did spend some time in uh new
zealand
first off the whole country is a beach
basically or right next to you because
it's like there's a you know oh you
gotta go to pacquiao beach you
this is know nice [ __ ]
oh yeah of course you did uh
[ __ ] the yogi yogi yeah
which i saw in the theater no because
you and anna my two but yeah my two pals
were in it um
oh man you're great that's a perfect
example of a movie where like a
performance like that is so
unsung nobody's gonna watch that and be
like oh god the acting because it
doesn't support acting but what you're
but what you're doing in it is so
[ __ ] good um
and hard i know how hard those you know
because you're acting with the green you
know with the little tennis balls and
you're great in that tom you and anna
are so good that's never been said
before and i really appreciate it
well because i but i know what it takes
i know i can say it i have authority
i know you do that's right you guys did
that in new zealand the people were just
so great you know like everybody was
just
you know it's like it's a country of
like just spontaneous and generous and
genuine humans and that makes your daily
life
better you know you look at what they're
doing oh yeah look what they're doing
with the pandemic look what they're
doing with you know like with gun gun
laws and you're like
these are just people who get it they're
regulars like oh this is bad let's go
let's get rid of it you know this is
good let's do this no yeah save
ourselves by doing this let's do that
you know what is like 100 days and no
recorded cases it's like
it's amazing you know yeah there's
there's a lot to be said for like common
sense you know and the kiwis yeah you
know that's a place that i would be you
know quite happy and i also wonder what
it's like to be one of those people that
goes off the grid and lives in like one
of those like beach island i remember
thinking like
lost as a tv show
shooting in hawaii
those guys have got this figured out you
know what i mean yeah he's just like oh
yeah you're gonna go shoot your show in
hawaii are you okay
you know so yeah i know i've never had
that experience really but um i've heard
from people who are like yeah it's the
best uh why would it not be
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who who would they be oh this is
this is one of those questions
i i mean for me someone who's uh like
tom hanks someone who's you know
directed and um performed and is uh an
american icon i know it's not like three
people but it to me it's like if i could
sit down and talk to that guy about
his challenges and what his way of like
making the world a better place and how
he approaches
um his fame and his pride his projects
is like that would be that would
definitely be a meal well spent yeah i
agree i would love that too um
who who is your favorite this is gonna
be even more of a challenge i know uh
who's your favorite muppet uh who's that
behind that darth vader mask
you will never guess
you know
like just
you know then i started thinking like oh
wait a minute like there's a couple a
couple more i i kind of can't do without
even like you know if i go up to wall or
if it's down in the balcony just kind of
like you know yeah
the pillar didn't get
like just the worst jokes and like the
fact that they the fact is somebody
thought let's put people in who hate the
muppets who are muppets yeah
brilliant joke of that yeah like this is
when you know someone knows the muppets
well when they say waldorf and statler
instead of like the classic statler and
waldorf oh you the the way you describe
them um i love beaker and bunsen
honeydew probably for the similar
reasons i like
laurel and hardy uh yeah i like that one
is kind of like the
is the authority figure the taskmaster
and
and the other one is just kind of going
along with it and not as bright and
and they look funny to me uh i love
those two i love the swedish chef i was
always fascinated by his hands
the fact that there's hands yeah
oh yeah
and yeah i mean
you can't really go like i remember like
even fozzie bears like
you know a baroness natural habitat a
student baker like
like just it's so big right so big and
broad you're like okay
i love that too it's weird to say to
this now i've never never occurred to me
but there was like a real humanity to
them you know like
fozzie bear had real like pathos and
there's there's a great montage in um i
i think it's muppet to take manhattan
where they all go their separate ways
yeah
it's really like heartbreaking where
they're like missing each other yeah
yeah
if you really want to
just rip all the emotions out um
there's a beautiful tribute that they
pay to jim henson at his funeral have
you have you seen this on youtube where
they've yeah
i imagine that yeah they say i don't
just knock you down
so
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life physically what would you pick
that's a great wow it's a great question
you could go rig really really youth but
then you're not grateful
you know what i mean um
like
i'm not here here's a perfect example
you know i played college basketball and
uh i was uh a pretty quick guard
um
and uh
but i i relied so much on physical
ability and i became a much better
player in my 30s like like not even not
even close i was more confident
um you know my playing days were over at
the end when i'm playing days i mean
like you know college competition but
yeah um i was just like if i'd known the
things that i'd known
you know in college that i know now the
way i can control things the way i see
the court the way i play off tendencies
the way that i don't just rely on doing
like one
what like i'm you know like i'm crafting
something a little bit more i'm setting
somebody up a little bit more like you
just became like a smarter
um
it's funny i feel that way about acting
for sure
though it's like you look at the stuff
that you did when you were young you're
like oh god you know yeah um yeah i i
personally can't look at it like and
because it's just you know and then
you're like oh okay
you're you're always
you know you're you're always climbing
you're always trying to learn you're
always trying to yeah trying to get
better you know
yeah i don't know that's why it'd have
to be a combination of that's why the
the fun thing the fantasy element of the
question is that it would be
purely physically i mean it would be
like what your body was like and what
your
how you were physically and then i guess
coupled with what you know now
uh
i guess you don't want to be like a
three-year-old
or did you
or do you yeah i don't know plane all
the
time and doesn't have far to fall and
gets back up and it's just like it's
true if you look at like little children
and one of the great things that they do
is like they contort their body into
like if they're going to read a book you
know they could read a book like
you know like well it doesn't have to be
we're like we're sitting in a chair
whereas like a kid is like and you see
them you're just like that's perfect
there's no like there's no conditioning
that's occurred that said like this is
how you must read a book you must be in
this yes that's the past and which is
yeah there's something joyous about that
like oh i'm just oh yeah i'm just
discovering and exploring all this stuff
yeah yeah well see that's the thing that
we get to we get to do versions of that
i mean we we're encouraged to play which
is you know again
this 12th time we've said gratitude but
one of the things i'm so grateful for is
that
we get to play like that and not have
those societal
constraints about
how you're sitting and
we're encouraged to be as
you know free as possible and free like
a kid is yeah you're creating something
and it's like anything anything goes you
know yeah
it's just like yeah that's a no that's
one of the best things about it isn't it
yeah oh god yeah um
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick
that's a really good question
you have a dog yeah and that might be a
good call a dog because
they're like they're getting like the
best of the human experience right
they're not getting any of the anxiety
they're not get they're just like i'm
happy to see you
we're gonna spend time together you're
amazing let's share a meal you don't
have to eat i'll eat um i gotta go crap
so let's do that together right um you
know i gotta go pee let's go do that
together you know and like okay man
let's just like just run for a bit and
then now that i'm done running
i'm just gonna lie here yeah you know
tom really quick yeah i ask everybody
how they want to be
or if they think about this if you think
about being remembered or your legacy do
you ever think about things like that
and and
certainly now are you um do you ever
think about how you want to be
remembered that's such a that's such a
great question i think uh i think the
short answer is
no i don't i don't think i i don't know
that i think about
legacy
for legacy's sake um to be
perfectly frank i don't know that i
spend time considering and perhaps i
should i think my philosophy comes down
more to like you try and like win the
day and you you know you tend to fail
again and again and again but you're you
want the effort to be there right to try
and set as good an example as you can
you know like that's one of the mantras
perceive from gratitude make it better
be grateful for for your time do that
now you know one of the greatest
weaknesses i think i've always had is
looking beyond now and so
legacy is born out of trying to do
things the right way not that i'm saying
i i do that but um it's not a legacy in
terms of what you are leaving or what
how people think of you or it's uh how
you live your life it's it's it's a
day-to-day it's a legacy that will
whatever continues of of you
let's say um will be the result of what
you do today and um with this question i
i think it'd be better to draw attention
to
my failings because
you know
you know
in a sports analogy the losses always
tend to hurt more than the winds you
know what i mean and so i think that i
think you're you're striving to
accumulate wins
and knowing that your
your reality is you know a multitude of
losses
that you i guess are striving daily to
try to turn into wins i just got
suddenly very jealous of your kids
because um
they uh they have such they have two of
the best um
parents i'm thinking i can't wait to
meet them one day they're they're gonna
be i would be shocked if they weren't
like exceptionally
um evolved you know just impressive
people because uh
they got they got two of the best
parents um they're very i can't wait to
meet him very loud
oh i bet well well i just love you so
much your face awesome to see your face
you always it's my week i can't wait to
see it in person yeah man
all right love you see you buddy
[Music]
so
well well well that happened yeah better
definitely well well well he has i love
his elves me too yeah he like he's just
such a burst of energy isn't he like a
burst of positive
without being phony i know right you
know he really he genuinely seems like
he loves being alive yes you know yes he
seems like he loves life yeah such
positive what did they call schwa de
vivre
yeah yeah mom used to say that a lot
yeah she did now it sounds pretentious
i know but he does have that
like a zest for and i remember that
about uh i was so spoiled to have that
as my like earliest formidable memory of
being an actor a professional actor but
formative oh
not formidable
[Laughter]
yeah forming formidable
oh boy but anyway i was lucky because he
uh just brought that to a set every day
and
and that
you know
i'm sure it's like that in any um line
of work where the person on top so to
speak uh he kind of sets the tone for
how to be and tom really did that and it
just brought out the best in everyone it
was such a great environment to work in
it's funny he said that he would want to
have dinner with tom hanks because he's
always kind of reminded me of tom hanks
he's got that like
just effortlessly charming
wholesome relatable quality to him yeah
i never visited the show because i was
in college at the time and i i just met
him for the first time a few months ago
at that basketball game we went to oh
wow so so bizarre i'd like to know
for so many years and and oh that's so
weird i was a fan of a show obviously i
watch but i used to watch that show when
i was in college like in the common you
know every hallway yeah because we'd
have a tv in our room so like we would
all watch the show in the in the common
room so i i was so aware of him for
years and i heard you looked up to him
so much so it's strange that i uh don't
know him but when i when i met him it
felt like oh this is he's exactly like
his character on the show he's just like
just breezy friendly
uh like funny charming guy and for those
of you who've watched who watch the show
his best friend played by josh randall
when they're together
they're very much like those two
characters i i saw eugene levy the other
day except he won the emmy which is
obviously very well deserved he's a
genius but it struck me how different
eugene levy was from the characters that
i know him so well from like waiting for
goffman or you know uh mighty wind or
something he seemed
just so
but whereas tom to me is like
i mean it's re he's really playing a
version of himself i think which is not
easy to do that's not like to say he's
not his verse at all and now i really
want to see the flat i you know i'm
embarrassed a bad friend that i haven't
seen the flash because he plays a bad
guy on that show he plays a villain
there's a huge following that show huge
i know and people who are tuning in to
this episode
because they love the flash are going to
be sorely disappointed
and sorry and uh the guy who plays the
flesh grant gustin is supportive on i
know him from instagram he's like my
instagram friend he just seems like the
nice he seems like a younger version of
tom uh and so i i really need to watch
that show uh i heard it's great it's
great
but anyway um it was very moving how he
talked about his dad who just passed
away and
and how uh he imparted that very
important lesson on him imparted
um to count your blessings and he talked
about his dad as being a natural warrior
so he had to overcome
that kind of natural predisposition in
order to be grateful and
aware of you know
what's the good things around you yeah
so he doesn't get hung up on yeah and i
realized when he said that like oh god
of course i know that there are people
who are predisposed to worrying and
people who aren't
uh but i've never heard it said
so uh like obviously yeah clinically
yeah like he was a he was a warrior yeah
he was a natural warrior and i realized
oh [ __ ] i'm a natural worried yeah me
too and and that somebody could overcome
that that's impressive yeah that his
father whom i'm never met was able to
overcome that natural predisposition and
yeah and make a point to do so for not
only to better his own life but to
better the lives of his kids those who
the kids who are really absorbing his
energy and and looking to him for
guidance i mean
that's admirable and then you see the
product of that which is tom who to me
i mean it's hard for me to imagine a
more
evolved person i mean i i just i so
admire
his ideology his mindset you know the
way he sees the world the way he behaves
i
i just really admire him
mm-hmm he's like fred rogers yeah he
does mr rogers he does he does he's
wholesome too he also like
you could tell he didn't run he didn't
really want to swear yeah he said ethan
a couple times
yeah which i find really charming me too
and he's like it's funny though but it's
it's not um
i think he uh
hit the nail on the head when he talked
about your penchant for lateness
i think he's completely right because
you are someone talk about a natural
predisposition you're someone who is
naturally predisposed to being late and
i i will say you've gotten better over
the years at being on time but your
natural state is lateness and he said
and he's right
that you never
really got better at at not being late
because he said in a very nice way yeah
because people always wanted to see you
and once you showed up at a place people
were excited that you were there so you
never learned your lesson that's not
good it's not good but but i'm thinking
of there we have a friend a friend in
common who uh does not enjoy your
lateness no and does not let you off the
hook easily i so with him you're always
on time yeah so it's just about it's
like i get stressed out meeting him when
we're leading up to meeting him i'm
stressed out now because i'm meeting a
friend supposed to pick up a friend
today from the train station and she's i
know when she's arriving it's like but
there's it's not for another you know
hour and a half two hours but i'm
already kind of stressing about it you
are yeah that surprises me yeah well i
was dating a girl once who um we didn't
fight for the longest time we had like
the first i don't know how many months
were just like bliss and uh
and one day i was late picking her up
and she got very
very upset so with this one particular
male friend and all women you're on time
yeah pretty much
yeah it's just who lets you get away
with it that's not good i i someone said
to me once and i i'm sure there's truth
to this that it's a microaggression to
it's a subconscious microaggression i i
don't know if that's true i think it's
just i don't know maybe not an
aggression but like certainly a sign of
some sort of a lack of respect i think
if there are no consequences to a
particular situation i think a person
won't change i've gotten better with
waiting
especially now like i mean we're all
getting better at it i think it used to
drive me nuts if somebody was
five ten minutes late i hated being idle
you know and and i hate to say this but
maybe the phone has something to do with
it like well i can see it like i didn't
want to say that yeah i can look at my
there's something to do now always i
know it's funny he was imagining how
annoyed bruce willis must have been
working with you
and he's probably right i'm sure bruce
was annoyed working with you he was but
also i think at the same time i think
tom probably
sees you and will always see you in a
way as a 20 year old kid that he used to
work with unless you haven't spent that
much time with him over the years that's
true you might be kind of stuck that's
true as a kid that's interested in his
brain less mature i know i've matured as
an actor i've definitely i'm looking at
those outtakes or those dailies from
shooting that show with tom i was
just so undisciplined having said that i
do think if you were in a movie with
bruce willis now
the 40 year old virg virgin of you
that's freudian
the four year old four year old no no
wait a minute the 40 year old version of
you would probably still annoy him
you know what i mean yeah of course
totally grown up and become
sophisticated no but also like bruce
wasn't crazy about
ad-libbing antics antics
yeah but that makes it sound like
i was going way outside the you know i
was going outside my lane he wasn't he
wasn't into fun
not really
he he
he definitely loosened up more as as we
shot maybe a future guest oh it'd be
great not if he hears this no i mean i
mean even if he hears this i think bruce
is probably like confident enough to be
like oh okay well yeah i was a little
annoyed in the beginning and
i i wasn't crazy about ad-libbing yeah i
just don't think he comes from that uh
that some people are predisposed to add
some people are more school and uh
aren't into it it's a very different
it's you don't have to do that when
you're certainly when you're bruce
willis no he can do whatever he wants he
um tom got very excited by the lightning
round questions and yes he was so
excited
to answer the questions you know he's
got such a child-like enthusiasm oh
that's a great question yeah he's so
great and i liked how he really thought
through the sports one in a way that i
don't know if we've had a guest yet who
has thought it through in like a very
real way like
my favorite sport is this but
do i have the realities of playing do i
want to be a 40 year old with a potbelly
yeah who just has to do one thing every
five days and get paid millions of
dollars that seems pretty appealing well
because he
takes sports very seriously he does he
like loves work and remember on the show
and for the
two percent of you who watch the show
still listening um they tom tom's
character and his best friend used to
play uh
10 10 this game called 10 bucks like for
10 bucks would you go and do this they
were hypothetical games basically like
would you rather type games that came
from tom and robert the creators
doing similar kind of things they like
to
they they like to
play with questions like that kind of
like idiotic hypotheticals which is
familiar yeah it sure does let's read a
letter okay
how would you say this name because i'm
tempted to say brigid bridget bridget
yeah i guess bridgette i knew a couple
bridgets you really yeah why would you i
mean i wonder how often in her in
brigid's life she has to clarify
bridget that's with a d not a t you must
constantly be and i'm sure i'm sure a
lot of it's bridget yeah i'm sure a lot
of brigids have to say by the way it's
with a d yeah a lot of bridges probably
have to say like frigid
oh you think probably like the way like
fridge that's easy that makes it easier
it makes it easier right they're
probably sick of having to be like it's
a d instead of like girlfriend
i was just there you don't bother to
think of cure when it comes to like
describing him my name is kier it's like
beer with a k yes line yeah he says it
even though it's not spelled beer with a
k it's pronounced
it's k-e-i-r yeah
there's so many times where i think now
when i think of cure when i think of the
name here i'm like immediately because
he said it's i've been around
that many times it's a beer with a k
okay
um subject uh thank you i would thank
you i would you rather
thank you
am i losing my mind i think she means
that i is like a little barrier like oh
my gosh oh thank you thank you slash
would you rather it's like a straight
it's like a very erect slash it's a
direct slash
thank you slash would you rather
justin and christian
my name is bridget writing to you from
chicago illinois it's frigid here
no no i'm kidding i'm sorry
i got so excited
um no sorry i never i don't know why i
bought that you also said it as you
looked at me with a little mischievous
look
you totally telegraphed that my name is
bridget writing to you from chicago
illinois my sister georgie
another cool name georgie i like girls
but yeah but you know now not that
they're no no there's a guy's name it's
all fluid
uh but i think of when i think of
georgie well are you sporty used to be
but now you haven't seen it
uh
i did yeah it did
oh you saw it i saw it um with georgie
oh that's right yeah scary uh joe how do
you spell georgie uh g-e-o-r-g-i
not e
no wow they have some
cool parents yeah some e hating parents
[Laughter]
uh my sister georgie or gay orgy
and i listen to you guys every week and
i wanted to thank you for being a beacon
of light in these strange and difficult
times
that's so nice bridgette we're
i mean we're not making fun of her name
but we've been like
talking about i'm celebrating her name
yeah yeah that's true
um your conversation at the end of every
podcast always makes us laugh and feel
like it's okay to laugh
to quote ralph waldo emerson as one
casually does
what is success to laugh often and much
to win the respect of intelligent people
and the affection of children to earn
the appreciation of honest critics to
appreciate the beauty to find the best
in others to leave the world a bit
better whether by a healthy child a
garden patch or a redeemed social
condition to know even one life has
breathed easier because you have lived
this is to have succeeded i'm gonna cry
that is incredible
what an incredible
quote
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna read it again okay
what is success to laugh often and much
to win the respect of intelligent people
and the affection of children to earn
the appreciation of honest critics to
appreciate the beauty to find the best
in others to leave the world a bit
better whether by a healthy child a
garden patch or a redeemed social
condition to know even one life has
breathed easier because you have lived
this is to have succeeded
it's a great question wow
you've made us breathe easier oh wow
thank you how beautiful
would you rather okay now would you
rather
that's a tough pivot to make but
if anyone can make it i think it's
bridget
uh would you rather be on a sinking boat
with brodie quint and hooper awesome
question from jaws
wow and have a great white approach oh
it's interesting that kind of what we
were talking about in the beginning
of being so afraid of animals that you
that's when i would
i would swim like a like
who swim aquaman aquaman
would you rather be on a sinking boat
with brodie quint and hooper from jaws
and have a great white approach or an
overturned jeep with tim and lex murphy
joseph mazzello and ariana richards from
jurassic park and a diner approach i
mean dinosaurs
in the distance
their stomachs are rumbling and they see
a dino a greek tiner no less um
huh
uh i my answer is very easy but um
see i would i would much much rather
hang out with those three guys from jaws
yeah richard dreyfuss uh roy scheider
and uh robert shaw robert shaw uh i'd
much rather hang out with those guys
than the two kids from jurassic park
nothing against the two kids from
jurassic park uh but that's not the
question it's uh
the question is i'm glad that's the
answer by the way the question is uh
would you rather with a shark because it
doesn't matter who you're with at that
point right it's just who's how are you
gonna survive
i would pick the jaws crew
well also even well no you know what
even in terms of the animal like i would
rather be with those guys especially
quint especially robert shaw because he
could i mean
they help help help right i mean i don't
think no offense to young joe zelenorian
richards i don't think they're gonna do
that much to help us as much as like uh
that's true
and roy scheider
he was so cool he was so cool i had such
a man crush me too you know
i got to do a reading with him shortly
before he died yeah and he was just he
smelled a little bit of uh cigarettes i
remember but um i'm not gonna say sea
water no no
no he's you know he's not really a
sheriff in a small one what he needs
no no he's not
he is yeah yeah weird yeah but um
he he had this cool musk is my point he
looks like he has a cool mom yeah
doesn't he and and he was really kind
and like i just
yeah i thought he was so cool um anyway
uh great great question but i would say
uh
in general i've
so much more confidence in my running
abilities than my swimming abilities so
for that reason i would choose the
dinosaur because i you're gonna run away
and
then the second main reason is chances
are i'm gonna die in either situation
and i would rather
die seeing something
like a dinosaur something uh majestic
and not nothing you're not gonna
appreciate there's nothing other sharks
aren't majestic but i'd rather have
experienced a dinosaur i know what
you're saying but there is i've been
extinct for how long i know but there
will be no part of you when talk about
adrenaline kicking and when like you're
afraid for your life there's not gonna
be
i don't think there'll be enough of you
to even register that like oh whoa but
at least it's a die i get to see this
creature that may be but the if there's
an afterlife and i'm looking back on my
final moment you can like commiserate
with uh not only communicate but i could
have that experience in my toolbox
toolbox of experiences
yeah i guess so you can like
charm
amelia earhart or something yeah sure
um
definitely pick the dinosaur so you're
assuming that you're going to die in
either case i'm not assuming but i think
there's a very good chance yeah i'm
going to pick the shark because i think
you have a better chance with those guys
and the ship is sinking and i've seen
jaws so i know that like some of the
stuff floats and you can float on it and
you still have the guy i mean maybe i'm
reading too literally into it because
you got the gun you have and sharks i
don't think are as
bloodthirst sharks aren't like great
whites are i mean you can kick them in
the eye and stuff i mean you
i always think about like you're also
not maybe the most appetizing meal for a
shark right now
you know you're you're skinny yeah you
like all that hair
i think a shark might be turned off by
you right now okay
i'm not defending whereas a dinosaur
wouldn't you know care but also you
think about this you're on jurassic park
if you beat the shark then you're kind
of home free i mean you have to like get
back to land but
in jurassic park let's say you even
managed to escape that that you're stuck
in jurassic park for the rest of your
life joseph mizella and ariana richards
from jurassic park i know but but it
doesn't include the actors or they don't
assume the characters i know but it i
think it's just surviving that situation
i don't think it means that for the rest
of your life you're in jurassic park
and you've got to just rest your life
you're not hanging out with these three
guys on
the ocean yeah i guess i haven't you
read too much too far into it i guess i
would take the
and that also oh yeah okay what great
questions great questions um thanks
bridgette and thanks for watching you
know so uh ralph waldo i'm flattering
yeah thanks to everyone listen thanks
especially to my guest my friend dear
friend tom and uh check out you know
check out that quote really applies to
him oh yeah yeah you know there's a
great episode of ed uh episode 16 i
recall um where it was all about
transcendentalist we're learning i'm a
high school student we learn about um
thoreau in class and i want to do i'm
going to go back to
the land and live as the road live
deliberately live deliberately yeah
that's similar to i mean emerson was a
transcendentalist too right they those
guys
really they knew they knew what was up
yeah they did they were cool
uh anyway um but weirdly didn't like
irish people i'm not irish no i know but
i recently read but they were they had a
real problem with ira not all of them no
thoreau did bro they were staunch
abolitionists i mean they were like
really into the rights of man and you
know tolerance and and yet they're in
there like except for the irish i know
well the irish were really
castigated when they were um first came
here anyway that's for another episode
that's for when we have uh who's that
mma guy who uh
the guy who like struts around with
conor mcgregor conor mcgregor yeah i'll
save that for the conor mcgregor yeah
he's dying to be on the show what do you
eat before a big fight who's your
favorite muppet
uh thank you to all listening and if you
guys want to write in our email address
is life is short
wondery.com
and uh thanks again to our wonderful
guest tom cavanaugh and we will talk to
you all next week
thank you life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
miesh lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producers are well
there's marshall louie and hernan lopez
for wondering
have a good week bye
[Music]
he said the frustration was that oh
doesn't this guy look like me yeah
do he was supposed to be maybe yeah it's
pretty insulting to me
what do you think
please tell me i'm better click that guy
please i mean he's younger you're
kidding really am i better to be my mad
guy
uh what i'm the wrong person wow judge
your looks like that geez do i think too
much of my likes or do you not do you
think you're that handsome but then that
guy then those two guys need the
monstrously guy i think he played a
scary guy but he has like nice features
and
he has like a killer mask on and like do
you think you're better than me yeah
i
not as handsome really lindsey graham
yeah you don't think i'm as handsome
it's that's a really nice angle that was
a great picture at least yeah actually
that was like in general i think
that's a good picture from two lindsay
looks like ryan
yeah
that's a really good picture of him in
this commercial
lindsey graham had such different hank
of it in reality i think
uh you're better looking than him
you